dereck sent a chain letter to his
friends asking them to forward the
letter to more friends the group of
people who receive the email gains 9/10
of its size every three weeks and can be
modeled by a function P which depends on
the amount of time T in weeks
Derek initially sent the chain letter to
40 friends write a function that models
the group of people who receive the
email T weeks since Derek initially sent
the chain letter so pause the video if
you want to have a go at this
alright now the way I like to think
about these let's just create a table
with values for T and our function P
which is a function of T for some values
that we can just pull out of the
description here so when T is 0 when
it's been 0 weeks since Derek initially
sent the chain letter how many people
have gotten it when they tell us he
initially Derek initially sent the chain
letter to 40 friends so T equals 0 P of
T or P of 0 is 40 now what's an
interesting time period here it says
that the email the number of people who
have received the email gains 9/10 or
increases by 9/10 every three weeks
every three weeks so after three weeks
so three weeks have gone by so I'm just
adding three to t what is P of T going
to be well they tell us it's going to
gain 9/10 of its size so it's going to
be 40 plus 9/10 times 40 which is going
to be equal to what well that's equal to
40 if we factor out a 40 40 times 1 plus
9/10 or you could say this is equal to
40 times
whoops 40 times 1.9 or another way of
thinking about it after three weeks
we've grown 90 percent that's another
way of saying that the number of people
who receive the email gains 9/10 of its
size you could say the group of people
who receive the email grows 90 percent
every three weeks and so if we go
another three weeks
so plus another three weeks I could say
well let me just write this is six weeks
well how many people will have received
email was going to be this number it's
going to be grown another 90% so we're
going to multiply it times 1.9 again so
it's going to be 40 times one point nine
times one point nine we're going to grow
by another nine-tenths growing by nine
tenths is the same thing as multiplying
by one and nine-tenths the one is what
you already are and then you're growing
by another nine-tenths so this is the
same thing as 40 times 1.9 squared you
go another three weeks nine weeks we're
going to grow another 90 percent so
you're going to multiply by you're going
to take this number and multiply by 1.9
again which is going to be 1.9 to the
third power and so what's going on over
here well we can see it's an exponential
function we have our initial value and
every three weeks we're multiplying by
one point nine so one point nine would
be our common ratio so we could say that
P of T is equal to our initial value for
T times our common ratio one point nine
and we multiplied by one point nine
every three weeks so we could just say
how many three-week periods have passed
by well we will take T and divide it by
three T divided by three is the number
of three week periods that have gone by
and there you have it and notice T
equals zero one point nine to the zeroth
power is one so forty times one T equals
three that's going to be one point nine
to the first power three over three and
so we're going to grow by ninety percent
and so on and so forth so feeling pretty
good about this